läuft oder was geht
herzlich willkommen hier zu einem video
am abend was ich als auch gerade dann
wenn ihr egal es gibt drei oder vier
oder 237 über 70 ein paar dinge
ansprechen und zwar erstens wurde mir
mega oft in die kommentare die sonne
blendet ja so egal wie ihr wollt mega
auf den kommentare geschrieben luca du
hast immer noch das falsche ware texture
pack dummköpfe nein habe ich nichts man
darf beim text schipek alles verändern
nehme dass er falsch man darf beim tec
speck als mann darf beim texture pack
facebook das gui verändern und die
schwerter und halte sachen die pigs oder
eine axt oder eine schaufel oder da das
halt so das heißt ich habe facebook es
ist allerdings mit dem sex we also mit
dem sex anzeige menü schriftart
schaltflächen die z-max einfach viel
schöner finde
und ich habe noch die specs spätes
schwerter und so alles reingepackt das
wollte ich nur sagen wir haben halt alle
da geschrieben
der spaß hat immer noch das teilte
texture pack du trinken noch ein strahl
ruhig alles wird gut
alles ist gut die sonne scheint mir
direkt in die fresse die sache nummer
zwei mit wasser zu tun und zwar geht es
um die einblendungen die ich immer
benutzte viele sagen ja das ist mega
dass du das wohl niemand die kommen wir
meistens so minütlich kommt aber so eine
einwendung viele sagen allerdings auch
luca das ist way too much einblendung
way too many to many ein blitz hat drei
seiten den kommentaren die eigenen sagen
megageil machst einfach so weiter die
anderen sagen ich finde zwar ganz gut
aber du machst es zu oft macht dass man
mit weniger und die dritten sagen
scheiße du zerstörst damit die stimmung
erst mal die leute die meinen ich sollte
mit komplett auch schon unsere zerstörer
angeblich die stimmung
mein part in faro ist es nicht für gute
stimmung also doch ich bin jetzt kein
stimmungs kaputt machen mich selbst
nicht in der favoriten rolle dass ich
jetzt auch alles mögliche gut
hinterlegen müsste mit perfekter musik
und ich muss spannung erzeugen und alles
mögliche ich möchte das ganze ein
bisschen auf den arm nehmen quasi weil
sich hier mit so alvaro kämpfen
so nah liegen pure emotionen und dann
komme ich da einfach her geschossen und
in der übelsten situation wo wir grad im
kampf im kompletten typ und sagt dann
die definitiv nein definitiv nein ich
finde es witzig deswegen ich feiere das
und deswegen bleibt drin deswegen alle
die sagen ich scheiße mach es raus luca
dann schaut euch war bei mir nicht an
wenn ich jetzt nicht ändern ich kann ein
bisschen weniger davon machen
allerdings ich anders nicht das heißt
nicht dass ich wirklich kooperativ mit
euch bin aber es geht halt einfach darum
das ist mein kanal meine videos und wenn
es euch nicht gefällt dann nimmst du
nicht löse aber dann solltet ihr es halt
wirklich nicht schauen weil ich möchte
nicht mehr diese kommentare lesen ja das
ist voll scheiße mit den einblendungen
damit machst du die stimmung kaputt wie
so schaut es dann nicht ein hallodri
film das aus der gleichen perspektive
mit mir zusammen könnte es bei ihm schon
da macht er keine einwendungen oder
schaut bei einem anderen team nehmen es
mir nicht böse aber ich will es nicht
aus eine dritte sache es geht um das
buch und zwar haben sehr viele mich
gefragt wie ist das mit jetzt
autogrammstunde muss man sich da eben
die tickets kaufen oder wie läuft das ab
nein das ist alles frei
die könnte einfach hin kommt es ist in
der meier schnelle köln irgendwann ich
meine 26 september
ich bin auch noch mal dann im oktober
noch in frankfurt barbara buchmesse oder
irgend sowas da kann man auch und kommen
dazu werde ich aber noch alles möglich
sagen und was ich noch bezüglich des
buchs sagen wollte ich habe sehr viele
bilder am start blende ich jetzt gerade
mal ein paar bilder eine können dann ihr
wollt gegen die jetzt mal passieren oder
so wenn ihr euch die genauer anschauen
wollt da stehen jetzt keine inside
inside in inside informationen braucht
aber nur damit ihr so grob seht wie das
ganze design in etwa werden soll
natürlich auf ein paar bildern finden
jetzt noch nicht bilder drauf und die
texte sind vielleicht ein bisschen
komisch und da sind auf dem notizzettel
am rand wo ich noch was hin geschrieben
hatte
allerdings sind das so groß die bilder
die das buch nachher dann auch aussehen
soll deswegen ich weiß ich hab dir
verbesserungsvorschläge sagte jo das ist
schön ich habe versucht das ganze ein
bisschen pickt sich zu halten mit zu
pixeln blöcken
ich weiß nicht mehr gefällt es richtig
gut und ich freue mich wenn es rauskommt
ehrlich gesagt die allerletzte sache
wenn ich noch ganz schön reden möchte
habe ich noch nicht in warmbad sechs
morgen gesagt allerdings wenig fahrt 6
und erlebt haben sollte eventuell
wer dich in barth 7 darüber reden und
zwar werde ich aus sarow nicht rausgehen
aber es geht um was anderes aber das
werde ich in europa 7 erzählen das heißt
wenn ihr das genau wissen wollt müsst
ihr übermorgen warum schauen da würde
ich mich freuen wenn ihr einschaltet und
sonst wenn ihr das video gerade sieht es
ist ein mittwochabend und ich bin
übermorgen beim rowland und dann nach
zwei wochen an der nordsee das heißt ich
bin im urlaub ich hasse das cola zu
trinken von blick sieht man brauche also
aufatmen summer vacation und werde dann
nicht so aktiv sein was spontane videos
angeboten video das sich aus dem
oderbruch lade ja nein vielleicht im
spot kameraden gefallen hat das daumen
hoch da oder halt nichts ist